[Music]
I don't drive a Bentley I've never been
in one
[Music]
rich what happened to the vlog I know
it's been such a long time since I
uploaded a proper sort of day in the
life type video as much as I enjoy
making them as creatively gratifying as
they are to create and share with all of
you I'm juggling so many things in my
life right now and I simply just
couldn't justify the time required to
shoot and edit these things so it's been
a minute but I have good news for you
I've got a new creative collaborative
partner Rhys once you come over here
this is Rhys Rhys Robinson say hi hello
Rhys is a talented filmmaker editor you
might have seen some of his work on this
channel you shot a vlog for me yeah a
year ago right
yeah the balanced one that one did
really well he also shot and edited all
of John Joseph's videos on his channel
what is he yeah the hard truth right
so he's the hard truth guy Rhys is
staying with us this summer and we're
going to be working on a whole bunch of
cool video projects so lots to look
forward to in the weeks and months to
come sit back enjoy this video and any
last words peace and plants that's it
man thanks for being here
enjoy
an interesting opportunity arose today
I'm going to see a couple friends I
thought it might be interesting for all
of you so I thought I would take you
along for the ride
[Music]
hey guys doing it oh yeah cuz he doeth
been a Jitsu party man I doubt that go
on rich I think we met one before yeah
long time ago in a Walkman still wellman
shops looking good man cool
all right let's see it look at the eyes
that is gorgeous whoa
beautiful man look at that you see I too
on here yeah it's the eye - so the guy's
shimano stepped up and said like baby so
the guys waiting steady at Shimano
supplied all the components here this is
my old bike I think I got this from you
guys
in 2011 maybe what year did I get this
bike from so I checked the dates cuz I
was looking for year old fit files and
your first Balcom was in 2011 yeah what
are the differences between these two so
the big difference is is that this was a
bike that was mass-produced in Asia
mm-hmm this bike is made in Italy so
handmade in Italy and while this bike
was laid up and made to a formula this
bike was made on a per rider basis so we
made that one we made them in five
different sizes and you could pick your
components and we would build it to suit
this bike is literally made for you so
this is essentially 100% bespoke where
it's made by you know guys who've only
ever made bicycles their entire life and
from the minute it hits the production
line they know that this bike is being
made for rich roll who's this height who
needs these measurements who weighs this
much and does this type of riding
so basically basically what you're
saying is this is sort of franco bikes
advantages
everything you make is custom to the
customer right come in you measure them
you fit them and then the bike is
specifically made for that individual
rider rather than just taking a size off
the rack and trying to make it fit right
and with Balcom a store we had before we
were able to personalize essentially
from the after the frame we now tuck
that personalization all the way to the
frame in carbon so that allows us to
really do what we've always set out to
do and do it I don't drive a Bentley
I've never been in one and I've never
been in a rolls-royce but I know what it
sounds like when I close the door in a
Toyota and I would imagine that the
relative difference is like closing the
door on a Rolls because you literally
hear nothing
whereas this when you hear the shift and
you feel like you hear things through
the carbon it's sometimes that hollow
carbon amplifies road noise that's not
at all the case here it's like dead Sam
[Music]
top of stunts stop road which one of the
more
popular climbs the Santa Monica
Mountains so it's cool about the top of
Mount Road and this overlook is that on
one side you have San Fernando Valley
and then come over here and you got this
incredible view of the Pacific down to
Malibu there's a little bit of smog but
if you trace down that way you can see
Santa Monica on a clear day you can see
Catalina and beyond but not the clearest
day today first impressions on the bike
it's incredible it looks a lot like my
other bike but the performance
experience of riding it is completely
different
it's unbelievably light incredibly
responsive but also comfortable and I
think where I noticed it the most is in
climbing the acceleration is just insane
it's my first time riding di2 electronic
shifting and that makes a huge
difference
so thanks Julian
and Hector and everybody at franca bikes
for putting this bike together for me
absolutely love it and very grateful to
you guys now I'm going to descend stunts
so I'm gonna see how this bike descends
but I have a feeling it's gonna be a
beast
[Music]
[Music]